just i knew that you had two ex-wives
named tammy so i was hoping that there
was one that you got along with and
nope i hate them both on my deathbed my
final wish
is to have my ex-wives rush to my side
so i can use my dying breath to tell
them both to go to hell
one last time would i get married again
oh absolutely
if you don't believe in love what's the
point of living tammy's just a woman
a nice woman you know she's not a
murderer
she's not a dragon it's really good to
see you ron
you've aged horribly are you
the son of a [ __ ] that didn't oh my god
what is your problem nothing's changed
has it he set
when you meddle in someone's personal
life it's just so
rewarding
oh yes baby got it
can i speak with you for a second i know
what you're doing
you don't care about ron you're just
using him to get lot 48 for your library
leslie that's crazy and correct
why are you doing this les there are two
kinds of women in this world
there are women who work hard and stress
out about doing the right thing
and then there are women who are cool
hello tammy
oh hello ron i didn't see you come in
i was just checking myself for scoliosis
and straight as an arrow
just like somebody else i know jerky
call off the dogs you and i both know
that in my entire adult life i have
never checked a book out of the library
oh my god she's amazing tom what the
hell are you doing
same thing you're doing celebrating
pawnee's finest i believe you know my
date
tammy swanson hi ron oh
hi ron hey ron i'm sorry is seeing
your ex-wife on my arm making you
uncomfortable gee
i can't imagine why or can i
oh i like this song you want a dance
table oh yeah yeah
oh i know tammy seems scary but really
she's just a manipulative psychotic
library book-peddling sex-crazed
she-demon
it's time for tammy and me to bury the
hatchet once and for all
everything will be fine
[Music]
it's been like this for hours
hey swanson snap out of it
leslie congratulate us
ron's got one just like it on his penis
oh yeah
what the hell happened to you well
you may now kiss the bride
it's been kind of a crazy night come
back come on
it's not real man she's just messing
with you he's lying ron stay out of this
glenn
it's tom and i'm not lying i'm not gonna
let you destroy ron you're just gonna
have to ow
ow oh he's attacking me ron kill him
[Applause]
that's enough hey baby
you almost had me again
but seeing you pick on this pathetic
defenseless little man
hey he reminded me what kind of a
monster you are you're a
joke you're not even a man anymore oh
and by the way
last night i faked four out of the seven
so did i oh let's go son
red alert swanson your ex-wife is back
no kidding donna not her the
other ex-wife
tammy one she's in your office
hello tammy ronald
that's enough small talk what do you
want you remember what i do for a living
i trust
yes you ruin people's lives
you're being audited ronald i don't care
and why is your mustache trembling i'm
here as a friend
call it nostalgia or perhaps guilt for
all the times i tried to smother you in
your sleep
i don't need your help wrong you do
what you're so fond of saying it's a
free country
good luck i hope you don't go to jail
sit up straight you're not doing your
breaths any favors
thank you honey
your breasts look amazing is this true
you only spent 40
on clothes in the past five years sounds
about right how did you meet
tammy one technically i've known her
since i was born
she was a candy striper at the hospital
she helped deliver me
oh my god i grew up in a very small town
600 people everybody knew everybody else
we first took up together when i was 15.
awesome
god it was a little scandalous but
everyone feared her so they kept their
mouths shut
tammy may i use the restroom remember to
wash your hands
okay you know what let's cut the crap
is this audit even real in a sense yes
but in another truer sense no it is not
i want ronald back but i had to learn
about his finances to make sure my
future was protected
i'm impressed he's acquired quite a bit
of gold
you gold digger
you are literally a gold digger
the thing i love about tammy is she
calls me on my crap
every guy needs that
it's time to settle this ah
an old-fashioned prairie drink off oh
what's in that jug it smells like jet
fuel
that's swanson family mash liquor made
from the finest corn ever grown on
american soil
its only legal use is to strip varnish
off of speed boats
if you win he's all yours and if i win i
bring him back to the farm for good
pour it i'm thirsty poor me one too then
let me in here
i'm gonna join you and if i win
ron stays here with us leslie no don't
drink that
we use it to burn warts off of the mules
poison oh
i made a mistake i made a mistake
this ends now
yeah mom you're going back to the farm
and you hmm you're going back to hell
fine
i got what i came for anyway i found
your underground safe i stole half your
gold
that's decoy gold you think i'd leave my
gold in a locked safe buried underground
where anyone could find it
you don't know me at all yes i do i knew
you
the minute you were born i intend to be
there the minute you die
ron your family's weird
this could end up being the best night
in ron swanson's life i am so so happy
for him
hello you gorgeous craftsmen
wow look at this room so much wood
ready to be worked
me
you